joining us here on the rich eisen show
are two guys whose highlights i used to
do on the back end of my sports center
career and here we are 20 years after
their drafting
just 15 spots apart back in the day now
uh teammates once again for a fifth
straight year and their knuckleheads
podcast that can be found in the players
tribute
it is quentin richardson and darius
miles how are you guys doing
good good glad to be here thanks for
having me you got it quentin absolutely
it's i i remember
doing your highlights back in the day
when you guys came up for the clippers
it's it's like a reunion right now the
three of us
yes
yes so um when you're getting ready for
talking about a draft right now what are
your what are your draft day memories
you first quentin what was that
like for you 20 years ago now best day
ever
best day ever i can remember uh you know
i got i was i was privileged enough to
be able to go
uh get get invited to the green room
and for me obviously i got picked 18. i
i felt i felt and i still feel today i
should have been picked higher so even
though it was like getting drafted at 18
was tough for me
everything was kind of worth it once i
saw i was going to the clippers and i
was going to be with my boy d miles and
it was going to be a lot of people that
i already knew so for me it was
disappointing going that low but it
still was
hands down one of the best days ever
what about you jerry
mills like he said one of the best days
ever uh
just leading up to it just uh getting
ready for putting your suit on and
getting measured for your suit
and all that stuff i never got that done
before and you know everything was just
a new experience for me and you know the
nba is
the biggest league ever and you know
when you go in that green room you get
to walk up on this stage when you get
this
shake mr stern's hand man it was just a
dream come true
where's that suit now does it exist
though oh
man that's in the archives
you don't know where your suit is no i
can't say that
we can we can we can we can stick our
chests out and say we
we aren't one of those worst birth suits
worst suit ever is on the draz day
draft day we we were you know we were
cool we were in the middle we weren't
trying to go crazy but we felt
comfortable and felt like we looked
pretty good
all right now now i'm i'm mandated to
ask who who who has that
award worst suit ever who's that oh
jaylen rose hayley rose is up there with
that red joint
baylor neither of you stuttered
you both spit out the same name at the
same time crazy right there
carl malone had a a yeah carl
was pretty pretty pretty too jalen
i forgot about that red one i remember
sitting there thinking to myself what's
he doing wearing ohio state colors
like what's up it's literally the first
thing i thought like what's up with that
like you know and he's just mazing blue
through and through
you know detroit players that is right
there exactly
so you guys knew each other obviously
from the aau days right that where where
did you guys
first meet darius would you remember
your call the the first meeting with you
and
clinton uh i i went to a spotlight
uh tournament in uh in illinois uh iau
coach invited me to opposing been a top
hundred
in the state and uh i got invited to it
i haven't played high school ball yet i
went to uh
where i'm from seventh through ninth was
junior high and ten through twelfth was
high school so
that summer he invited me to this top
planet
camping i was doing real good and uh
first time i seen cue as he came over
there and
and was like who was this this young cat
dunking and all that stuff and he was
asking iau coach who was i
and you know everything else fell
through there
that's when he was what seventh grade i
was in tenth grade
wow how tall were you in the seventh
grade darius
oh i was six something
my mom was five nine and and i was her
height in
fourth grade
in fourth grade
wow i got darius miles and quentin
richardson here the nut
who chose knuckleheads for the podcast
who chose that one
it was a mutual agreement yeah it was
kind of
just like when we was coming up with it
it was kind of like what are we going to
call it and then it was like
it kind of tied back into the whole
thing and it just it kind of just made
sense and it was like um
it's kind of cool you know what i'm
saying like one of my favorite guys
that's on espn michael wilbon he always
says
uh see you tomorrow knuckleheads and i
always thought about that and i was like
you know this
it could be a cool little name because i
was gonna ask you because i i remember
all this
and am i doing it right with this part
of it or is it is it
okay right yeah all right so this is
what what was this what was that what's
the genesis of
so so the origin story of that is
like we said we got drafted jerry's was
18 i was 19. so we still were uh
very much into high school basketball we
we loved the aau scene we wanted to see
whoever the top high school players
maybe were going to play like we like
you know we from i'm from chicago big
city and i'm like this la they got a lot
of the best basketball players so we
wanted to see
and we began going to those games and um
anybody who knows
la is like d mal has lived in marina del
rey
and our practice facility was la
southwest junior college and
literally dead in between there on the
road going to and from on lincoln
is westchester high school so we kind of
sparked up a relationship with those
kids this was a signed item
bottom big red uh
trevor ariza trevor reese is the name
bobby brown they trevor
trevor probably had the biggest career
of those guys but
so he was a sophomore then when we first
met them and this was originally their
celebration for their they this was
something
they did with their team but we got cool
with them and they were like yo
you know we would go to their practices
so they're like yo y'all should do our
thing in the game if y'all get a dunk or
something so
that's literally how it begins so we did
it a game or so and then
when we came back the next game the fans
was like yo
they wanted to they can encourage and
would like keep doing it so again it
became
me and d was like man maybe we could get
it on the video game because back then
they had to raise the roof on the video
game from tiffany cooper and all that so
he's like maybe we get on the game
and the first time it i think it really
got big because one of the reporters
asked darius what did it mean and he
gave an old joke like i had to kill you
if i tell you like you don't say i can't
tell you what i'm saying
and it kind of grew bigger because we
never told them what it meant
but i think i don't know if it would
have been a big as big a deal if
everybody knew what it meant the whole
time but i think that's definitely the
origin story it really was those guys
trevor reason and his high school
teammates it was their celebration
and we kind of got it from them
representing them and then they kind of
took on the life of its song
that's basically the way you remember
too darius yeah yeah that's basically
where we was representing them and like
i said we did we used to do it if we get
dunks and i was getting way more dunks
than cute so
just started doing it for everything
that he did like a three-pointer
everything so i was like he's doing it a
little more than me let me do it
kind of like a momentum thing for our
team though but
you know 20 years later it's still a big
thing 20 years later darius miles and
quentin richardson here on the rich
eisen show
again right before the nba draft and
right after uh
season five of your podcast knuckleheads
drops on the players tribute jamal
murray
is your first guest and man i just loved
every second of watching him play and
just watching his
star rise pretty much and i know
it came at the expense of the clippers
but i wonder what did you learn from him
i mean what did you glean or learn
not from him but talking to him about
him what did you guys learn
i think i think the whole league learned
that
he he's one of them like uh now every
team has a solid point guard
and now when you're going against the
steph curry's you're going to get some
top point guards
now denver has a point guard that can
compete with them point guards and i
think uh the whole league know that now
yeah i think i think one thing i learned
from him is um
i mean obviously i know that i knew this
already but he he was a picture of
toughness
being being shown in different forms
like you know a lot of people think
toughness is when you see a big physical
strong guy or a brute who can knock
somebody down
but i think he he he and his whole team
to come back from three to one that many
times he showed toughness perseverance
and determination and then
as you said obviously uh he put the
entire league on notice that he's he's a
superstar and
you know right now like not incoming
he's a superstar he showed the entire
league that he can
close games he could go 30 40 50. he
could lead his team he could bring his
team back
he's a superstar all right now let's
let's try and spit a little truth here
then
why do you think the rest of the league
reveled
you saw nba twitter just lit up when the
clippers went out 3-1
why do you think the rest of the league
seemed to really enjoy
that loss of the clippers why
i think the expectation for them was was
so high
you know the expectations in there was
so high you know we're in the dnas now
you can't slip up like that you gotta
you gotta walk it like you talking
so if you're gonna talk it like that you
definitely gotta walk it so
when the expectation you didn't even
make it to the lakers
i feel like you you deserve to get
everything that you had coming
me i'm and you know we we we we clippers
guys we we clippers homers and all of
whatever you want to call it so for me
it was it was
it was i picked them to win a
championship this year and so
i think it was a situation where i can't
say them
each to a man and call and call it call
them out as a man
individually but as a team it looked
like they took everything for granted
like it was it was a foregone conclusion
we're going to get to the finals we're
going to play the lakers we're going to
do it was like
they were none shimano about it in their
in their effort for it and
that that was what was shown i mean the
glaring things were obviously they had a
lot of
injuries back and forth and people
leaving above when those things but i
mean
even still it was kind of like they
attitude where was the sense of urgency
it was i didn't see a sense of urgency
out of them and i just
that was disappointing to me because i
really felt like they had a team to win
it
well especially since at the end you
know i know you said you don't want to
call anybody out specifically but
so let me do that then um you know
i was particularly surprised to hear
paul george say afterwards
that this wasn't going to be the year
anyway you know that they
that they needed some time to jail or
that
you know somebody who who clearly was uh
contractually there for at least only
two years to say well there's more
runway here
that one really surprised me that one
kind of took me back
after you lose 3-1 like that what about
you guys
it surprised me too but like
you know i don't you know i'm a die-hard
clipper so don't
want to ease up on them i just feel like
they just really didn't get the
chemistry
how they want i feel like there was a
very talented team and just
talent was beating a lot of teams that
they was playing
when it came down to the x's and o's
the the i know you'll play we know your
plays and we got to play it out for
these seven game series
i feel like that that caught up with
them you know they had a lot of new
players on the team
injuries guys not there and
you know you got to have that chemistry
guys got to be together guys got a
bond like if every championship team has
a special bond
that season that they never that they
can never forget
it lasts the rest of their life you
could never forget this championship
season
we had together and it's a different
type of bond and i feel like they just
didn't have that and then get the
opportunity to get that
yeah i think the evidence was was in the
changes that were made man i think
when you have a like i said from the
outside looking in
it looked like it was it was not a sense
of urgency
was lacking there so i mean when you
can't hold the players accountable it
goes to the coach and that goes that it
fell right in dark river's
left you know i'm saying like rightfully
or not rightfully or not and i think
it's a situation
that kind of stamps it when you hear one
of one of the star or lead players come
out and say
this wasn't the year like why would he
be thinking that
you understand like if that should have
been like when you say that surprised
you it surprised me a surprise dee that
surprised everybody i would expect his
teammates to have like if somebody was
sitting next to him to be like what
like we was like that and for me for me
in my mind when i heard him say that to
me that meant that the message the
battle cry
this is you know i'm saying the sense of
urgency wasn't there like that's the
situation where he's saying like if you
were a championship type team
if you listen to those lakers it was a
battle cry it's a togetherness they all
on the same page
this is the time is now you can't have
one of your your top guys saying that
this
this wasn't the time where we had a you
know we playing a long game or something
yeah so how do you think tyler's gonna
rectify this or change it how do you
think his hiring
what do you think of it i think i think
uh you don't care about none of that
i think he had an opportunity to see
what was wrong
like in a you know right there by being
an assistant coach i feel like
he know what he has to change within
himself
i like his coaching staff that he chose
there's a lot of wisdom and
and stuff in this assistant coaches and
i just feel like it's a new voice
for everybody it's a new story they
think to make a lot of moves
i think yeah i i feel like t lu the the
the best thing he has going for him is
like obviously he's a championship coach
and he's going to come in with a fresh
voice
but he had front row seats to see
everything that went wrong
he knows everything that needs to be
corrected and everything that needs to
be fixed
situated he had front row seats to see
that so he has that inside look
in that inside track and he can go in
with his ideas and his fresh thought
process and say this is how i'm gonna
approach this and write these wrongs or
fix what's broken over here and over
there so i think he has a a
real good position on that so uh in a
few minutes i have left with uh with you
guys quentin richardson and darius miles
the knuckleheads podcast it's gonna be
on the players tribune for fifth
straight year just
dropped yesterday the fifth season right
here on the rich eisen show before i let
you go let's chop up
um the idea that hardin wants to maybe
join
kyrie and durant in brooklyn
what do you guys think of that quentin
what do you think of that idea
it's absolute ah that's what you think
darren i mean look i i think so too
um but you know uh
nash being the coach i don't i don't
know i don't know if fans would like it
either you know what i mean like it's
just
it's it's a return to i thought uh we
were done with super
teams but maybe not what what do you
guys think i i think listen man
i i'm excited for it that if that could
happen i'm excited for my main man steve
nash and
and amari over there because like dee
said i mean they
they already are you know a championship
caliber contending team in that in that
little group but i think
if obviously if they get a james harden
you add that to to kyrie and kd
that instantly puts them in that top one
or two three
positions for the championship eyes so
for me i'm excited from that standpoint
and um
as far as all of the super team i mean
everybody's still teaming up and banding
together and doing those type of things
maybe not three or four guys
like in like you know with the ron d
wade and bosch but i mean there's still
a lot of tandems all over the league so
i mean i don't i don't think it would be
something that would be that crazy or
that scoffed at it i mean
i don't think that would guarantee them
a championship either i think that would
put them right there at the
at the pinnacle of it but i mean we all
know that it's a lot that goes into
winning the championship
so i think that would like i would be
extremely excited for stevie to be
be in that position in his first year uh
man my friend was talking about today uh
if that combination
happened who would be the chris bosh of
that
that's a great question
that combo with with kyrie and katie and
james who would be the chris boss of
that combo
that is a great question because what
you're implying for those who might
not be fully aware is somebody's gonna
have to take a step back
somebody somebody's going to have to
give up a couple shots here and there
certainly uh a little bit
less than they're used to feeding
the interesting thing that the
interesting thing in this dynamic is
that the person who would probably be
the most willing to take the step back
is the person who shouldn't he's the
best player out of them all like kd has
the personality where he would probably
say hey
don't worry about me but you the alpha
you the you you you the best player so
it can't be
you that says that so that's there's a
scenario
i think kyrie will have to
turn into a a different type of point
guard
he uh more facilitate more passing
and instead of and we just need you to
get them big shots when we need you but
it's not going to be
he going to be the guy that averaged
close to 20. i think
kdn horton should be the guys that
averaged 25 or more
and kyrie be the guy to average the 20
or the 18
to back him up and i feel like that's
the championship
recipe i feel like if it be any other
way if you try to put james harden
in the third position which is the bet
probably the best scorer in the league
the best score in the league you trying
to make him the chris bosh
of any situation what team can he go to
when you
make him a third
question so and then i guess just
wrapping up
pulling on this thread here don't you
think nash that would be obviously a
major coaching
task for him but don't you think nash
would be able to talk to kyrie about
exactly what you're talking about don't
you think he would be
able to at least say to him point guard
to point guard
bosch this up a little bit you think
yeah
i think so i think that's the reason
that this championship guaranteed
he got the guy that facilitates more
than anybody the guy that
everybody wanted him to shoot the ball
so much
and he's the guy that's trying to tell
kyrie we just need this side of you to
win the championship and
i think he got to do it yeah for me
steve that like if we were all like
x-men and we had superpowers that's
steve steve nash's super
super mutant power is that he can make
it work like i watched him with our
season with the sons it was
me joe joe johnson sean marion and mari
started meyer and we
you know everybody had their egos and
shawn was an all-star highest-paid panel
team
i had just got a contract amari was
coming out was about to be a superstar
and joe was just on the cusp of becoming
who he became so it was like
steve was amazing at being able to keep
everybody's personalities and
everybody's attitudes in check
and made it work so i mean i feel like
if anybody has a great chance of doing
that with this group i feel like that's
what steve nash brings to the table and
that's his special move
and i guess since you you did mention
phoenix there i i i'd be
derelict if i didn't ask you guys what
you thought about chris paul winding up
in the same backcourt as devon booker
all of a sudden that sounds like a hell
of a backcourt what do you think of that
so somebody don't got an easy first
round buy i don't know that much
that they gonna face themselves in that
first round and it's gonna be problems
you're saying that's good enough it's
still just good enough for the eight
seat is that what you're saying
7c i think they they definitely gonna be
they're gonna be a contender they're
gonna go through that eight through six
seed
and they're gonna be a team that don't
nobody want to play because they got one
of the best scores in the league
one of the greatest minds in nba history
at point guard
and you got some young guys like aiding
them backing that up so
i'm excited for them yeah i love that
move for them i mean seeing the impact
the
the cp made on that okc team and um
just knowing that he could do the same
thing for them and then reuniting him
with his old coach monty williams who
money would
have done an amazing job with that crew
already and i think
he he'll be a further extension of the
coach and
he'll make it that much more better for
that team i i think they they should be
extremely excited
out there in phoenix well guys it was
great catching up with you it's been
well over a decade and a half since uh
maybe we crossed paths and
it's been a long time so it's a pleasure
chatting with you congrats on your fifth
season of knuckleheads podcast available
on the players tribune and new episodes
available on tuesday all major podcast
services and online at the players
tribune
website let's do this more often if you
guys are up for it i'd love to do it too
anytime man congratulations to you
continually
doing your thing and we've been seeing
you forever and still see you so
congrats
well you guys look the same i might look
a little bit you guys are like the fine
wine you know
but good to see you guys that's quentin
richardson and darius miles knuckleheads
podcast again
every tuesday jamal murray uh kicked off
season five
just yesterday right here on the rich
eisen show